if you just bought your first deck of  tarot cards do not be overwhelmed the  most important thing is that you develop  a unique relationship with every single  card in the deck and how you're going to  do that is by getting to know all of the  different imagery and my recommendation  here is that each morning when you wake  up as part of your morning routine pull  a card and look in the little booklet  and do some reading about it and that  way each day you are going to be working  with a different story there's a  different archetype and gradually you're  going to be able to create connections  between your experiences your intuition  and the 78 cards in the deck